[संगीत]
ए
हेलो गुड इवनिंग तू जो सबसे पहले एक चीज
बता दीजिए की आप सबको मेरी आवाज सुने दे
रही नहीं तेरी चाट में जल्दी से बता दीजिए
यस या नो
थैंक यू
डिफरेंस अकादमी
लाइव क्लास फ्रेंड करते हैं तो मैं उनको
नर्वस नहीं करूंगा
तो एक और इंपॉर्टेंट यह है की जो लोग आज
फर्स्ट टाइम ही फर्स्ट दे ही इस क्लास में
आए लाइव क्लास में तो उनको मैं बताना
चाहूंगा की हमारा एक टेलीग्राम चैनल है
वहां से उसको
लिंक पर मिल जाएगा
उसको सब्सक्राइब कीजिए चैनल को जॉइन कीजिए
पर्दा जो भी नोटिफिकेशन होते हैं जैसे की
आपको कुछ डाउट चाहते हैं या कुछ और कोई भी
अनाउंसमेंट होता है तो सबसे पहले आपको
वहां पर आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो प्लीज
जाइए उधर जॉइन कीजिए आप लोग क्या करते थे
लाइव क्लास में आते हो लेकिन क्या
टेलीग्राम चैनल को जॉइन करते नहीं उसके
बाद आपके डाउट डाउट ही र जाते हैं आप लोग
को पता नहीं था
और शेयरिंग होती है बुक्स शेयरिंग होते
हैं बहुत कुछ शेर करते और आप लोग आपस में
बात कर सकते हैं आपस में डाउट क्लियर भी
कर सकते हो
तो
फिर से वही है मेरा नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए
ही करिए
और आप लोग क्या करते हो की
लाइक कर दे तो लेकिन कमेंट नहीं करते मेरी
किसी भी वीडियो पर आप लोगों ने अभी तक कोई
भी कमेंट नहीं किया अगर नेगेटिव हो तो
नेगेटिव ही कर दीजिए भैया मैं पॉजिटिव
कमेंट की उम्मीद नहीं कर रहा की आप
पॉजिटिव ही कीजिए
कुछ चीज बता देता हूं की जो बेस्ट कोर्स
है इसके पैरेलल में आपके नोट्स रेडी हो
रहे हैं डिटेल नोट्स जो भी पढ़ा रहा हूं
डिटेल नोट्स अगर आप लोगों ने उसका एक डेमो
देखना है तो आप लोग हमारे लिंकडइन पेज पर
जाइए दे ब्रोमीन के जो की है लिंक में
दिया हुआ है वहां गिरने के बाद उसको देख
सकते हो की हमने डीटेल्स में अभी रिसेंटली
एक पोस्ट किया हुआ है की काफी अमेजिंग
पोस्ट है वो खुद से पर्सनली हमारी टीम ने
बनाया है उसके आप जाके उससे डिफरेंस दे
सकते हो और आप लोगों को चिट्ठी टाइप हम
डेफिनेटली और ऑफ डी कोर्स या कोर्स के
बीच-बीच में आपके साथ आपको जो बेस्ट मिलती
रहेगी जितना करवाया वहां तक आपको ताकि इन
फ्यूचर आपको अगर नोट्स भी है और साथ में
अगर थॉट नोटिफिकेशन
ओके तो
एक काम करते हैं कंटिन्यू सेशन करते हैं
तो आप लोगों को लास्ट स्टेशन के और में
मैंने एक चीज बोलती आप लोगों को दिमाग में
एक डाउट आना चाहिए और अभी तक किसी का वह
डाउट आया ही नहीं है
अभी तक वह डाउट मुझे लगता है की किसी का
वो आया होगा
मैं वेट करता हूं एक दिन और या कुछ दिन और
वेट करता हूं क्या वो डाउट आप लोग लेक ए
पाओगे दिमाग में नहीं लेकर आओगे वो डाउट
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है वो आपका डेफिनेटली
होना ही चाहिए अगर आप बेस्ट गिफ्टिंग करना
चाहते हो या एवं आप कोई भी कमांड या टूल
रन करते हो खुद का बनके या किसी का भी
रूल्स आप रन करते हैं तो वो डाउट एक ऐसा
है एक क्लीनिक वाले बंदे को दिमाग में आना
चाहिए
तो कोई नहीं कोई नहीं परदाराम कंटिन्यू
चलते हैं की लास्ट सेशन मैंने क्या बताया
था की कुछ डिस्कस किया था कुछ पॉइंट
डिस्कस किया थे की हो बेस्ट प्रोसेस कमांड
था की जो कमांड लाइन जो बेस्ट है जो कमांड
लाइन वो कैसे प्रोसेस करेगी उसका छोटा सा
हम मैंने कुछ डिस्कशन किया था की भैया
पांच स्टेप्स होते हैं कोई कोई भी कमांड
वो फॉलो करती है कौन से पांच स्टेप्स हैं
टाकीसेशन कमांड
रीडायरेक्शन ये पांच स्टेप्स को क्या करती
है कमल लाइन फॉलो करती है
एग्जीक्यूट होती है आपकी वो कमांड जो भी
कमांड आपकी स्क्रिप्ट में होती है अगर आप
लोगों ने जानना है की ये थोड़ा सा इसके
बड़े में क्या एक्सप्लेन दिया था लास्ट का
5 मिनट का अगर आप लोग वो जानना है तो
प्लीज जो आज नए लोग का डायरेक्टली आज ही
आए हैं मुझे लगता है बहुत सारे लोग हैं की
है जो आज ही फर्स्ट दे उनकी क्लास होगी तो
प्लीज
इस क्लास को जॉइन कीजिए कोई सनी लेकिन
लास्ट क्लास को प्रियेश दे तू क्लास को
आपको देखना ही चाहिए एक बार क्योंकि एक
छोटा सा लास्ट की कुछ टाइम्स में डाउट से
सेशन से पहले क्या किया टॉपिक था वो आपको
पता होना चाहिए तो आज हम स्टार्ट करने
वाले हैं की जो आपकी एक्चुअल में जो बेस्ट
प्रोसेस बेस्ट के अंदर जो कमांड लाइन है
वो प्रोसेस कैसे करेगी उसके जो पास
स्टेप्स हैं उनके वन बाय वन बाय हम क्या
करेंगे 35 से 45 मिनट के अंदर वन बाय वन
बाय जो टॉपिक रहेंगे
टॉपिक रहेंगे उनको हम क्या करेंगे आपके
क्लियर करेंगे
नो बट हम डिटेल एक्सप्लेन ऐसे करेंगे ना
की आपको फरदर कभी भी कोई डाउट नहीं आना
चाहिए इसलिए इसी तरीके से आपको पता है
मेरा तरीका क्या है इस तरीके से एक्सप्लेन
करने वाले हैं तो सबसे पहले हम स्टार्ट
करते हैं हमारा आज का फर्स्ट टॉपिक है की
लेकिन फर्स्ट टॉपिक क्या है कोचिंग
सबसे पहले स्टेप जो मैंने बोला था कमल
लाइन
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है मैं जिसका नाम बोलना
हूं
वोटिंग इसको हम बोलते हैं
सबसे पहले यह हमारे लिए डिस्कस करना बहुत
ही ज्यादा जरूरी है अगर हमने यह डिस्कस
नहीं किया तो फिर मजा नहीं आएगा देखो
और काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है
नेक्स्ट कॉपी करेंगे
अब बात करते कोटी यह क्या चीज होती है
इसके बड़े में आपको डिटेल एक्सप्लेनेशन
करूंगा
उसको इफेक्ट करता ही करता है इफेक्ट करता
ही करता है की आपकी जो भी कमांड्स है वो
बेस्ट के अंदर बेस्ट सेल के अंदर कैसे
प्रोसेस करेंगे उनके हर एक पार्ट को क्या
करता है वह इफेक्ट करता ही करता है अगर
आपको वोटिंग का टॉपिक क्लियर नहीं है या
कॉन्सेप्ट क्लियर नहीं है तो क्या होता है
इसके करण आपको अपने कोर्स में या एवं आप
डेली बेसिस पर जो कमांड रन करते हो कई बार
खुद से आप कुछ चीज ट्राई करते हो तो वहां
भी कई बार ए जाति है बट उनमें इतना इफेक्ट
नहीं डालता लेकिन क्या की जब खुद का जब
बेस्ट प्रोग्रामिंग करोगे
वहां पर अगर आपका यह कोचिंग का कॉन्सेप्ट
क्लियर नहीं है तो आपको क्या है एरर देखने
को मिल शक्ति है
वोटिंग
इफैक्ट्स
प्रतिमाच
एवरी पार्ट ऑफ
आओ बहस
प्रोसेस कमांड लाइन ओके
थोड़ा
एवरी पार्ट ओके
जस्ट ए सेट ऑफ करैक्टर
[संगीत]
एस होते हैं आपके जिनका कुछ स्पेशल मीनिंग
होता है और वह स्पेशल परपज के लिए ही बनाए
गए हैं और एग्जांपल जैसे की
पर एग्जांपल जैसे की आप आपका जो एक डॉलर
सिंबल है
डॉलर
सिंबल ओके डॉलर सिंबल एग्जांपल
तो अभी
कोचिंग क्या है
आपके लिए थोड़ा सा कलर
हा ए आर ए सी टी ए
जो भी कुछ स्पेशल कैरक्टर्स होते हैं और
जिनका कुछ स्पेशल मीनिंग होता है अगर आप
चाहते हो की वह स्पेशल करैक्टर अपना
स्पेशल मीनिंग परफॉर्म ना करें उसका
स्पेशल मीनिंग आप रिमूव करना चाहते हो
उसके लिए हम क्या करते हैं कोचिंग का उसे
कर सकते हैं उसे करते हैं किसी भी स्पेशल
करैक्टर का या किसी भी करैक्टर का स्पेशल
मीनिंग रिमूव करने के लिए हम तीन तरीके से
वोटिंग का उसे करते हैं बेसिकली मैं का
सकता हूं की तीन टाइप के कोचिंग होती है
अगर समझ में नहीं आएगा रिपीट करना मैं बता
दूंगा
सबसे पहले कौन सी होती है
ओके थोड़ा
स्पेशल
मीनिंग
फ्रॉम डी
एक्टर
इम्मीडिएटली
फॉलोइंग
होता है अगर उसके आगे आप इसको उसे करोगे
आईटी बिल
रिमूव डी
तेल मिस्टेक
मीनिंग
इनसाइड ओके
रिमूव कर देगा
डबल को
डबल को वह भी आपको पता है
एवरी करैक्टर
एक्सेप्ट
डॉलर एक्सेप्ट डॉलर साइन
और
कैसी होती है
इनको छोड़कर डबल को क्या करता है डबल को
हर एक करैक्टर का स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव कर
देता है जो भी इसके अंदर रखें जाएंगे
उसका स्पेसिफिकेशन
मीनिंग रिमूव कर देगा जो इसके अंदर होंगे
और डबल को के अंदर जितने ट्रैक्टर सबका
स्पेस मेरी रिमूव होगा लेकिन छोड़ के डॉलर
साइन और बैक पीस लेकिन डबल को है उसके
अंदर एक फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी दी गई है अगर आप
क्या चाहते हो की कई बार आपके साथ ऐसी
सिचुएशन आए की उसके अंदर जितने भी स्पेशल
करैक्टर हैं कौन से
डॉलर
उसे किया हुआ लेकिन उसमें से कुछ जगह ऐसी
हैं वहां पर आप क्या चाहते हो की जो डॉलर
वहां पर करी ना करें उसका स्पेशल मीनिंग
नहीं होना चाहिए आगे आईटी इस विद्रोह
प्रिंट होना चाहिए कई बार ऐसी सिचुएशन
आपके सामने ए शक्ति है तो उसे कैसे में आप
क्या करना चाहोगे उसे कैसे में इसका
स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करना चाहोगे लेकिन
कुछ ऐसी भी जगह है जहां पर क्या डॉलर के
साथ उसका स्पेशल मीनिंग काम करना चाहिए इस
सिचुएशन में एक ऐसी फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी
प्रोवाइड की है की आज अगर आप डॉलर्स साइन
और बैटिक का स्पेशल मीनिंग रिमूव करना
चाहते हैं तो अब बैक स्लैश का उसे कर सकते
हैं डबल को के अंदर तो से काम करेगा जैसे
बैकलेस करता है इमीडीएटली उसका स्पेशल
मीनिंग क्या कर देगा रिमूव कर देगा यह एक
फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी डबल को के अंदर प्रोवाइड
की गई है जब एक बार किसी भी करैक्टर का
स्पेशल मीनिंग हम रिमूव कर देते हैं तो
उसे ट्रैक्टर हम क्या बोलते हैं
क्या बोलते हैं
मतलब उसका
एस्केप एडमिन सुना होगा
उसको हम क्या बोलेंगे
उसे कर सकते हैं और आपको फुर्थर क्लासेस
में हो सकता है आपको
मिल जाऊंगा
प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखाऊंगा
लेकिन तीन टाइप की कोचिंग होती है बैकलेस
सिंगल को डबल कोट्स अगर आप लोग इसको
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए एडरवाइज नोट
रिक्वायर्ड अभी मैं प्रैक्टिकल आपको
दिखाऊंगा
अभी हम चलते हैं प्रैक्टिकल अपने स्क्रीन
के ऊपर ये मेरी मशीन है
मेरी ओके क्लियर है
पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या चाहता हूं की मैं को
करना चाहता हूं मैं कहना चाहता हूं को
करना चाहता हूं अपनी कमांड के अंदर सचिन
और सचिन
और नितेश मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं
बट अगर आप लोगों को पता होगा नहीं बता
देता हूं की जो और है एम परसेंट बोलते हैं
जिसको हम इसका भी एक स्पेशल मीनिंग होता
है अपने सेल के अंदर और आप लोगों ने लेंस
की क्लास में इसको उसे किया हुआ है और जो
लाइनेक्स यूजर है उसको पता होगा क्या
स्पेशल मीनिंग होता है की यह क्या करता है
आपकी कमांड को बैकग्राउंड में रन करवाने
के काम आता है
किसी भी कमांड को क्या करता है बैकग्राउंड
करवाने के लिए काम आता है और इसका स्पेशल
मीनिंग होने की वजह से जैसे मैं आउटपुट
चाहता हूं वैसा आउटपुट प्रिंट नहीं होगा
हम अपने आउटपुट में क्या देखना चाहता हूं
लेकिन क्या ऐसा आउटपुट कर दिया ये देखो एक
बैकग्राउंड में चलेगी उसके बाद दूसरी
कमांड नोट को सचिन इसने रेड कर दिया जैसे
कमांड रन हो गई समझ में आया मतलब क्या हुआ
की एक स्पेशल करैक्टर की वजह से मैं जैसा
आउटपुट चाहता था वैसा आउटपुट मेरे को नहीं
मिला क्योंकि मुझे कई जगह ऐसा ही आउटपुट
चाहिए हो तो मैं कैसे करूंगा
तो इस कैसे में मैं क्या करता हूं अब
कोचिंग का उसे करता हूं इस कैसे में
कोचिंग करता हूं मैंने क्या किया
उसके बाद सचिन
मीनिंग रिमूव कर देगा और हिट इंटर कर दिया
अब मुझे इन पंजाब फूड चाहिए था सचिन और
नितेश ऐसे ही आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
लेकिन उससे पहले आपको ऐसा आउटपुट देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा था क्योंकि
इसका अपना स्पेशल मीनिंग था अब मैंने यहां
पर क्या कर दिया स्पेशल मीनिंग इसका रिमूव
कर दिया और अब मैंने क्या बताया
की आपने वेरिएबल के अंदर किसी जो विंडोज
है
मैं लिखा फाइल पाठ फाइल पाठ लिखा उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं इक्वल साइन वेरिएबल
कैसे डिफाइन लिखा
यूजर उसके बाद बैकलेस दें मैंने क्या लिखा
सचिन
तो मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा कोचिंग का उसे
करना पड़ेगा तो
रिमूव कैसे करूंगा मैंने इसके सामने को
बैकलेस लगा दूंगा इसके सामने
भी मेक और बैकलेस लगा दूंगा और इसके बाद
में क्या करता हूं
और जब देखो जैसा आउटपुट मुझे चाहिए था
वैसा ही आउटपुट आपको स्क्रीन पर देखना है
और ऐसा ही आउटपुट आपके वेरिएबल के अंदर
स्टोर हो गया क्योंकि मुझे है ऐसा ही
आउटपुट चाहिए था क्योंकि मैंने इसको क्या
कर दिया पोर्ट कर दिया कोर्ट इसको क्या है
कोटेड कर दिया है एस्केप हो गया समझ में
आया पर एग्जांपल अब मैंने क्या किया तो
ऐसा कर दिया अब मैं क्या चाहता हूं की यार
हरबान में क्योंकि जब हम स्क्रिप्ट
लिखूंगा तो हर बार यह पता चला की मेरे पास
10 यूजर 10 यूजर के लिए हम हर बार उसे
यूजर का नाम था ना टाइप करूंगा नहीं
लिखूंगा तो मैं सिंपली मैंने क्या फाइल
पास किया और उसके लिए मैंने क्या कर दिया
ये रहा इसकी जगह मैंने क्या कर दिया की
[संगीत]
सॉरी सॉरी
है इसका अल्टरनेट तरीका क्या है ओके यहां
से मैं टॉपिक थोड़ा सा आई एम सॉरी अभी
देखा है आपको पता है की इस तरीके से करना
है रीड करना है अभी और इसको राइट करना है
अभी टिपिकल है क्योंकि हो सकता है
की इससे कुछ ज्यादा हुआ पर एग्जांपल ये और
भी ज्यादा लाइन है उसके अंदर आपको ऐसे उसे
करना है आपको
हेलो एवरीवन
आई एम सॉरी पर डेट मुझे लगता है
बार-बार मेरा वी-फी क्या कर रहा है की
बैंड हो रहा है और उसके पास स्टार्ट
स्टार्ट हो रहा है तो मैं कनेक्ट भी नहीं
कर का रहा हूं तो अभी मैंने मोबाइल डाटा
से कनेक्ट किया है तो मुझे लगता है की
टॉपिक को कंटिन्यू हमें ने सेशन में करना
होगा तो डोंट वारी सुन ही जल्दी मैं क्या
करूंगा की आपका जो नेक्स्ट सेशन है उसको
मैं